dans le reportage ce sont les petites
combines ce qu'ils ont appelé les
petites combines des forains pour gagner
de l'argent notamment au jeu de la pince
vous avez déjà tous Voilà c'est le jeu
de la pince regarde avec cette manette
il faut diriger le crochet pour attraper
des peluches et autres cadeaux
[Musique]
le souci c'est que la pince est
capricieux bien souvent elle lâche la
peluche avant qu'on ne récupère le lot
en réalité dans ces machines infernales
rien n'est dû au hasard
c'est le forain qui décide des gains
derrière une trappe discrète au niveau
en fait de la technique c'est à dire que
en fait en travaillant sur sur les
réglages je peux dire à la machine voilà
tu gagnes tout le temps par contre je
peux lui dire voilà tu gagnes à 1 sur 1
tu gagnes un sur deux je dirais gagné un
sur trois ou un sur 25 vous aurez beau
vous acharner rien n'y changera la force
de la pince est réglée à l'avance
moi j'en peux plus aussi alors j'adore
Julien je n'en peux plus c'est
reportages oui tout le monde les trucs
et qui ils veulent mettre les gens sur
l'appareil les forains c'est un kif
d'aller dans une fête foraine on y va
pour le kif on y va pour le kiffe on y
va pour kiffer en famille moi je suis
j'adore les fins et le savent et je l'ai
je l'ai soutiendrai toujours les gars
ils font des animations ils viennent
d'un s'installer dans les villes ils
travaillent comme des chiens derrière tu
leur fais un reportage comme ça il y a
plein de gens qui vont hésiter à y aller
maintenant qui vont lui dire on nous
volent on nous voit les gars on y va
d'abord pour kiffer arrêtez un peu de
tout ils veulent on est dans une société
où ils veulent tous à lire c'est un truc
de fou ça veut dire ils veulent tous à
lire ils veulent ils seront contents
quand tout le monde sera au chômage la
magie non mais je veux dire là on kiffe
on va la fête foraine on y va pour rêver
on peut en savoir tous les trucs de tous
les sens
dans un monde les gens de pouvoir croire
ça règlement
reverser 95% c'est la loi tu vas pas
pour gagner de l'argent
Mathieu est-ce qu'on est en train de
dire c'est que au casino aussi ils
savent un peu qui va gagner parce que
c'est un moment la machine va donner
c'est là c'est c'est un peu ça aussi
voilà tu sais qu'à un moment je croyais
quoi sur les tickets même de loterie je
crois que les les les buralistes hier
soir ils savent le numéro du jeu oui
exactement sur certains influer voilà
oui moi j'ai pas du tout aimé ce
reportage qui était clairement à charge
en fait on fait passer les forains pour
des arnaqueurs pour des gens malhonnêtes
qui respectent aucune loi qui emploie
des enfants enfin la manière dont tout
était raconté c'était horrible d'abord
ils sont très riches d'abord
avec un reportage on peut tordre la
réalité dans un sens ou dans un autre
moi j'ai vu des gens hyper soudés qui
roulent pas forcément sur l'or et pardon
mais le truc de lapin c'est nul mais les
mec
ça vient eux ils sont pas d'ailleurs ils
sont pas hyper riches et plein de potes
forains ils sont pas hyper ils gagnent
bien leur vie bien sûr ils gagnent bien
leur vie et voilà et il travaille et
voilà oui ils essaient de se démerder
mais il faut arrêter alors regardez
après il y a eu le jeu de la cascade le
fameux jeu qui ressemble au casino on
met des pièces pour faire tomber des
lots on met beaucoup d'oseille pour pas
grand chose ils ont dit regardez
chaque soir elle accueille plus d'une
centaine de clients prêts à tenter leur
chance sa priorité attirer les joueurs
avec des cadeaux alléchants mais pour
décrocher le cadeau de leur rêve les
joueurs doivent d'abord passer à la
caisse en moyenne ils misent 30 euros ce
soir Mathias et sa copine Chloé tentent
leur chance sur la machine la plus
populaire la cascade
finalement au bout de quelques minutes
leur mise de 30 euros semble avoir payé
9000 fois avec 30 euros un score
impressionnant mais une fois devant la
vitrine déception Mathias et Chloé ne
tombe que sur quelques babioles
finalement le jeune couple repartira
avec une peluche
voilà alors c'est vrai que voilà là sur
ça
alors je vais te dire la vérité
un commerce il y a l'emplacement il y a
l'électricité le mec qui vient il n'est
pas gratuit il faut comprendre ça tu
payes tout oui mais c'est les gens
jouent ils ont envie de gagner un paquet
de chips à 4,50 € de quoi tu me parles
et comme ça le paquet de chips en vérité
ça veut dire c'est la magie de Disney
t'as compris donne-moi une chips et les
chips
on est dans un monde les mecs attendez
non mais après après comme j'ai dit tu
crois pas que tu vas aller gagner un
iPhone ou voilà non mais les gars on y
va pour le kiffe c'est une sortie en
famille tu sais que tu vas tu vas la
fête foraine tu as ton budget quand tu
vas la fête foraine tu dis voilà je vais
dépenser ton je vais faire telle telle
attraction mais tu vas pour le qui si tu
vas à la fête foraine pour te dire je
vais devenir millionnaire je vais gagner
toutes les pièces qui vont tomber ou je
vais gagner un iPhone ou une voiture non
je suis désolé voilà c'est c'est donc en
fait c'est c'est des trucs ça juste pour
[ __ ] les gens dans la merde
moi je suis d'accord avec vous le danger
c'est de stigmatiser les gens du voyage
mais ensuite là où je ne suis plus
d'accord c'est que mon cher Enoch c'est
quand même une gigantesque Carnac les
carabines sont truquées on apprend que
quand on tire la carabine c'est truqué
la grue la machine à pince c'est fait
pour que les gens perdent quand on met
de l'argent Cyril le disait là dans le
jeu là on est sûr de perdre pour avoir
l'iPhone c'est 6000 € 6000 voilà on joue
6000 euros on aura un iPhone
pour arnaquer les gens c'est pas c'est
pas nouveau mais c'est pas nouveau
ça veut dire que le mot est gros là là
tu prends un exemple c'est comme si vous
savez quoi c'est comme s'il y avait un
mur blanc de 10 m est un point noir et
tu vois que le point noir mon frère
c'est incroyable
et donc ouais donc là tu vois que le
point noir ben on voit que le point noir
les amis c'est parce que 1 et de la
fille on dirait que tout le monde vous
savez ce qui m'énerve c'est sur un fond
de racisme je vais vous expliquer non
attendez non mais c'est normal mais tu
es blonde yeux bleus mon je sais pas ce
que c'est facile tu as fraîcheur mon
frère tu es en fraîcheur
si c'est parce que c'est des gitans mon
frère au quotidien moi je le sais mes
enfants vont à l'école tu sais ce que
c'est d'être disant aujourd'hui il y a
pas d'association pour le protéger il y
a rien c'est-à-dire qu'il y a rien pour
les gitans aujourd'hui tu peux dire tu
peux mettre un panneau à l'entrée d'une
vie d'une ville interdit aujourd'hui
voyage fais-le pour les Fages fais-le
pour les homosexuels fais-le pour les
musulmans mais la ville elle coule mais
aujourd'hui en France tu peux ça veut
dire le Gitan tu peux tout dire sur lui
ça passe crème les députés se lâchent
attends je vais aller voir une femme une
mère c'est à dire c'est pas moi une mère
moi je peux faire des fautes de langage
je suis tu as vu tu as compris c'est pas
mon métier mais une mère elle dit les
gitans je veux pas ils volent de
l'électricité ils veulent de ça tu te
rends compte elle veut pas du temps chez
elle mais si tu peux dire ça à la
télévision c'est normal mon frère ça
veut dire c'est c'est un fond de racisme
je t'explique moi voilà comment je le
vois des vrais commerçants ils te diront
quand les gitans ils viennent à quelque
part ils achètent les bouchers va
demander au boucher allez voir les
boucher allez voir les boulangeries je
voulais juste vous dire un truc tu sais
que j'ai comme info sur les fêtes
foraines et surtout sur cette affaire
puisque j'ai un ami forain que
j'embrasse qui mène les graines il me
dit là le patron de la pince n'est pas
forain c'est un responsable événementiel
les forains sont en colère en plus la
machine n'a rien à voir avec celle de la
fête voilà donc ça c'est important donc
voilà donc attention voilà les forums
qui sont responsables de cette machine
ou c'est vrai qu'il y a pas mal de gens
aussi qui dit à Cyril on met plein
d'oseille dedans on croit qu'on va
gagner c'est vrai voilà ça c'est moi moi
j'ai mis des heures avec ma fille avec
la pince pour vous dire moi ça m'a coûté
un coiffeur
tu sais comment ça m'arrive du premier
coup je mets une pièce j'ai attrapé une
peluche aussi alors c'est vrai
je vais te dire ce que m'a envoyé un ami
et un autre ami voilà Mehdi que
j'embrasse mon Mehdi d'amour qui me dit
mon Baba je te jure que j'ai gagné
l'iPhone avec 20 euros au coupe Foire du
Trône bisous ton Mehdi c'est bon Mehdi
voilà voilà donc je vous le dis c'est le
tien non mais c'est bon alors on va voir
un autre extrait les trappes secrets
pourquoi on gagne peu dans ces machines
ils l'ont dit tout à l'heure les forains
ont des techniques bien précises est-ce
que c'est vrai ou pas ça regardez
pas évident de décrocher le gros lot
d'autant que Sandrine et son employé
font tout pour compliquer la tâche des
joueurs
oui
d'abord les gros montants seront les
derniers à tomber ils sont positionnés
loin du bord autres astuce alourdir le
devant avec des objets pour freiner la
progression
car en fait les pièces ne poussent pas
que vers l'avant mais aussi sur les
côtés en effet regardez à droite la
machine est équipée de Trappes secrètes
où on voit les pièces disparaître
et vous avez beau misé toujours plus
d'argent la plupart des lots les plus
intéressants sont hors d'atteinte
est-ce que ça c'est vrai est-ce qu'il y
a des grosses arnaques comme ça partout
mais déjà des grosses arnaques qu'est-ce
que tu as fait une grosse arnaque mon
frère on parle en quelques en quelques
euros et il y a des gens qui sont quand
même c'est c'est un gros budget pour eux
tu vois quand ils vont à la fête foraine
je te le dis vraiment je non mais tu as
vu les budgets qu'ils ont annoncé 100 €
200 qui dépend vous savez combien 1200
€, tu les as écouté les 300 € moi je
dépense 300 400 dirt tout le monde
dépense 100 balles par le gosse oh mais
on vit en France les amis les gens n'ont
pas d'argent fabrique 100 balles c'est
énorme par personne
tu as compris le mec il va pas dire je
dépense 10 balles pour le gosse tu as
compris ils disent des montants c'est
des montants qui n'existent pas ça
grandit
le reportage ils ont cassé le seul mec
qui mettait effectivement 100 ou 200 €
par enfant mais c'est facile encore une
fois c'est de la manipulation il a dit
aussi c'est toujours pareil c'est
toujours pareil qu'il a dit il est
devant la télé il veut briller le mec il
va pas dire je suis un crevard j'ai pas
dépenser d'un conduit la base mon frère
le mec après l'émission
qui cartonne dans les fêtes foraines
c'est le tir à la carabine tout le monde
est persuadé qu'on peut faire craquer le
fil mais comme il a dit il ne s'aide
jamais regarde on gagnait le cadeau il
faut couper la ficelle en visant à la
carabine à plomb le tarif moyen pour 15
tentatives c'est 20 € problème c'est
qu'il faut parfois dépenser beaucoup
avant de toucher la cible et encore tous
les clients ne repartent pas avec un
cadeau j'avais dépensé combien là
pourquoi une majorité de tireurs sur
ruine sans pouvoir rompre la fameuse
ficelle avec vos talents à la carabine
ça vous arrive parfois d'aller à la fête
foraine au stand de tir pour gagner des
peluches au risque de trahir un secret
qui est bien gardé les carabines sont
déréglées et permet pas au bon tiroir de
tirer correctement c'est à dire que même
même vous pourriez rater la cible et
vous gagnez pas la peluche à la fête
foraine voilà
voilà alors lui il est très bon dans son
domaine mais à mon avis il a pas fait
toutes les fêtes foraines le mec
attendez on le croit si on parole quoi
on a dit c'est vrai non mais en vérité
c'est on en est là mon ami il a dit
c'est vrai tu as compris non mais c'est
on est dans un monde de malade
du coup moi je pense qu'il faut arrêter
un moment de vouloir flinguer tous les
business c'est insupportable et oui les
forains ont fait un kiff quand ils sont
là voilà tu l'as dit tout à l'heure et
on veut tout flinguer on est dans un
monde où on veut tout flinguer
si c'est pas des musulmans c'est les pus
c'est les drogués les majeurs
[Musique]
il se passe arrêté par la police comment
tu veux qu'il les respecte comment tu
veux qu'il leur dites on va aborder
comment tu veux les mecs qui t'ont dit
pendant un reportage sur nos heures ils
sont racistes ils ont des méthodes
pas regardez c'est que des cowboys euh
ils font la discrimination ils vont donc
c'est sûr qu'il y en a voilà il y a
comme on dit de partout il y a des bons
partout il y a des mauvais partout dans
les rides dans la télé non non moi c'est
pas pour défendre ici dans les forains
aussi peut-être voilà mais quand tu
montes à chaque fois tu montes ce qui va
pas dans le truc donc le lendemain tu te
fais arrêter par la police tu dis écoute
j'ai vu le reportage hier laisse-moi
tranquille voilà j'ai pas envie de
parler oui Guillaume non mais on a
l'impression qu'en fait parce que c'est
des forêts ils ne respectent pas le fait
que c'est un business mais ils veulent
quoi en fait qu'on gagne un iPhone à
chaque fois en dépensant 1 € c'est pas
possible il y a un mec qui disait le
reportage qui l'a payé son manège 600000
€. il faut en vendre des tickets pour
rentabiliser le service
il gagne 1000 euros par mois donc faut
arrêter il était crédibilise parce que
si tu leur fais la même chose sur toutes
les entreprises toutes les entreprises
doivent faire du bénéfice excuse-moi de
couper la parole mais si tu leur dis si
tu leur dis les gitans sont gentils ça
machin personne la regarde l'émission
mon frère alors je veux pas défendre M6
mais si tu leur dis que tout le monde
est gentil tout le monde il est beau
voilà oui les amis mais je l'adore
Julien tu vois c'est vrai que voilà et
ça a très bien marché d'ailleurs ça fait
près de 3 millions de téléspectateurs
c'est un carton ils disent les manèges
rapportent beaucoup à certains forêts
qu'il y a un joli train de vie ils ont
un poste ils sont en voilà il sait pas
les villas c'est pas les fringues c'est
les voitures de sport ils disent que
c'est là-dedans qui met tout leur argent
regarde
chez les gens du voyage certains ont de
très gros budgets les forains notamment
on est sur une famille donc qui a de
très gros manège qui sont des gens donc
en place dans le Var avec de très belles
entreprises puisque c'est du 30 à 40
employés on vient de leur signer
actuellement ce magnifique poupée turbo
mais alors pourquoi ces familles
mettent-elles autant d'argent dans leur
voiture jusqu'à 20% de leur budget
mensuel
ce sont des gens du voyage sont des gens
qui voyagent donc ce sont des gens qui
ont toujours beaucoup roulé beaucoup
circuler et qui pour eux la voiture est
très importante vous savez très bien que
chez nous les gens du voyage on n'a pas
de grosses villas et tout ça donc quand
on peut se faire plaisir et s'acheter
une grosse voiture on préfère s'acheter
une grosse voiture qu'une grosse villa
40 employés
et les mecs ils ont pas le droit de se
faire un kiff non mais si on déconner il
bosse le gars il fait plein de monde il
peut pas se faire un qui il a envie ils
sont qui c'est d'acheter une voiture
[Applaudissements]
on l'a vu on t'a vu on t'a vu moi je
peux plus je vous jure que je peux plus
le gars il veut faire son kiff il va
acheter sa voiture il a 40 employés il
travaille il est pas chez lui en train
de de de de chez moi aussi le
documentaire c'est que pardon je lui
disais la pub c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
de cash dans ce domaine aussi qui a
beaucoup de casse et donc il y a
beaucoup de revenus qui sont pas
vraiment déclarés et qui a beaucoup de
casses
entendre alors c'est ce que ça laisse
entendre on est d'accord on fait les
impôts est-ce que tu est-ce que vous
allez déjà voir vous savez un PDG ou un
mec le mec il a une grosse bagnole aussi
mon ami ça veut dire que alors c'est pas
tout à fait la grève non mais est-ce que
ce que je veux ce que je veux dire par
là c'est qu'en direct c'est une honte
aujourd'hui la réussite en France ça
veut dire tu as pas le droit mon frère
tu gagnes tu gagnes ta vie tu as pas le
droit d'avoir une Porsche là ce que dit
Mathieu c'est que s'il y a beaucoup de
tout n'est pas déclarée c'est ce qui dit
voilà c'est ce qu'il dérange il y a des
gens comme ça ça fait pas forcément un
voleur en fait si vous préférez on
flotte entre les voyageurs vous savez un
monde secret qu'il n'est plus parce que
maintenant tu veux réussir une émission
prendre des voyageurs mon frère tu es
sûr que ça va faire une audience de fou
parce que les gens ils aiment bien taper
sur le voyageur j'en parle avec de leurs
mots Mathieu
excuse-moi
j'en parle à Mathieu le mec qui gagne
1200 € que Dieu le bénisse c'est dur de
vivre avec 1200 €. tu sais il voit ça à
la télé il se dit c'est de la faute du
gitan c'est lui c'est lui le problème en
France il paye pas ses impôts tu as vu
il y a une pauvre dame il y avait une
pauvre dame alors je sais pas si si vous
allez passer l'extrait peut-être je m'en
porte un peu il y avait une pauvre dame
la pauvre elle sait pas remplir les
papiers oh vous savez pour la CAF là
mais alors le mec qui gagne 1200 € le
pauvre qui arrive pas à joindre les deux
bouts ils se disent oh ça y est c'est ça
c'est ça
j'en avais parlé un peu à l'avance tu as
vu on est on est dans le futur on est
dans le futur
venir vous toucher le vacaf par mois
violette non dira pas plus pourtant
selon nos calculs une mère de famille
répondant au même critères peut toucher
deux fois plus sur sa déclaration on
peut lire que Violette affirme vivre
seul avec quatre enfants alors qu'elle
est en couple avec Michel et entouré
la CAF la considère donc comme une mer
isolée elle a le droit à 1650 euros
d'aide et non pas 800 se déclaré comme
mère célibataire la pratique serait
répandue chez les gens du voyage même si
violette n'en parle qu'à demi-mots
15 ans je suis comme ça je fais avec qui
donc voilà donc c'est est-ce que tu
expliquais inox c'est vrai que c'est
voilà c'est incroyable je déteste les
voix off répondu chez les gens du voyage
il y a une personne qui le dit répandue
sur les gens du voyage je déteste les
voix
ils disent qu'il veut le mec
merci d'avoir été avec nous Enoch merci
c'est gentil